foreign policy chief Catherine Ashton
confirmed that EU member states had
finally found a united position over
events in Syria Ashton said that there
should be no military intervention
before UN inspectors released the report
on last month's chemical attack but she
said evidence suggests that Bashar al
Assad's forces are to blame in the face
of the cynical use of chemical weapons
the international community cannot
remain idle a clear and strong response
is crucial to make clear that such
crimes are unacceptable and that there
can be no impunity the agreement
convinced Germany to sign a global
statement drafted at the g20 meeting in
st. Petersburg calling for a response to
the Syrian government sources said John
Kerry had refused to give assurances
that the US would hold off on a military
strike but he said the statement was a
step forward we are very grateful for
the statement that came out of the
meeting today with respect to Syria a
strong statement about the need for
accountability and I'm particularly
grateful for the president's comments in
the earlier this morning and the foreign
ministers support for the efforts to
hold the Assad regime accountable for
what it is done the minister said that
the International Court of Justice and
The Hague should look into prosecuting
the perpetrators of the chemical attack